the conspiracy theory that has been
widely debunked that being near someone
vaccinated against covid-19 can do
something to you has not gone away we
have another one of these very dangerous
Clips this is by the way
this is Lauren witsky Lauren witsky is
not some random person in the sense that
she was the Delaware Republican Party's
candidate for the senate in 2020.
thankfully she lost she is now claiming
she became sick after being around
someone
who had their covid vaccine and she
insists she's not crazy listen yeah and
the shedding is extremely real that's
how I caught whatever it was and you
can't tell me it wasn't a bio weapon
because I've had flus before I've had
you know tons of stuff wrong with me
before I've never experienced anything
like it it was like in your head it
stole your joy you couldn't like had
zero energy brain fog like it was almost
like I was poisoned it felt like
um you know and you know you can't tell
me covet itself wasn't a bio weapon but
I didn't catch covet I campaigned up and
down the state of Delaware she probably
had coveted 2020 during covid and didn't
catch anything I shook a thousand hands
didn't catch anything I was around a
family member who just got boosted
didn't tell me I've never been so sick
in my life and it wasn't like sickness
it was like I don't know how to explain
it but whatever is shedding off of them
it made me sick and I've never quite
been the same I'm not as sharp as I used
to be I go back and I wash my interviews
from 2019-20 or 2020 and I'm like wow I
was completely different person that
she's still very like I'm stupid no
really it did something to me and you
can't tell me it didn't because I know
it did and I'm not crazy right she's
definitely not crazy guys so listen the
most likely explanation is the simplest
which is she got coveted she was around
someone who had coveted and she got
covered the entire vaccine shedding
thing we've talked about it before okay
the idea of shedding is someone gets
vaccinated and then they shed something
off of their body
um it's not supported by scientific
evidence it's not a real thing the covet
vaccines that are used in the U.S don't
contain any live virus so you can't shed
virus and the concept of shedding
vaccine just doesn't really make any
sense now if you're sick with covid
then you are shedding the virus when you
cough and so on and so forth and it
seems that that is probably what
happened here now one interesting thing
she says she hasn't been as sharp and
whatever as many of you remember I got
coveted in early December I am
experiencing a long coveted symptom
which is my sense of smell is diminished
now I never lost my sense of smell or
taste when I had coveted
um it didn't go away but it was
diminished and what I realized now is
that it is still a diminished sense of
smell and honestly the the way that I
came to realize it is since having covid
I don't notice from just being in a room
with my baby daughter that she needs a
diaper change I used to just perceive it
from the smell people are understanding
I think what I'm saying I don't notice
anymore and my girlfriend will say does
she need a diaper change and I'll say oh
I don't know does she yeah it stinks in
here and I'll go I genuinely don't
notice that I can smell stuff but it is
diminished and I've read it can be 12 to
18 months thankfully I'm not
experiencing the brain fog that Lauren
whitsky uh seems to be struggling with
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below